I'll right everybody welcome to the
final keynote portion of our colloquium
today it's my pleasure to introduce
Malcolm Johnson who is was elected to
Deputy Secretary General of the ITU on
twenty-fourth of October 2014 and he
started his mandate on january first
2015 secretary Johnson has a very
distinguished career from 2007 to 2014
he served as the director of IT use
standardization Bureau in this post he
spearheaded activities in cybersecurity
climate change and accessibility he
increased the involvement of developing
countries a topic that we heard about
earlier today and academia and ITC ITU
standards activity he also introduced
the notion of free downloads of ITU
itu-t recommendations and initiated a
program to address developing country
concerns over lack of interoperability
and conformity to ite standards he
achieved a three-fold increase in the
activities of ITU stella combination
standards sector without increasing its
budget and so that's a huge huge success
to increase activities while not at the
same time incurring extra cost between
2003 and 2006 mr. johnson was the
international coordinator of the united
kingdom's office of communications where
he led where he had lead responsibility
for the united kingdom's itu mr. Johnson
graduated from the university of wales
cardiff with an MS and bs first class
honours degrees in 1976 he's a chartered
engineer a fellow in the institute of
engineering and technology and is an
honorary professor of amity university
in academia of the International
Telecommunication Academy he is fluent
in English and French and he also has
some knowledge of spanish so I guess
he's going to welcome questions in
multiple different languages so with
that please join me in welcoming
secretary Johnson
[Applause]
thank you very much David good afternoon
everybody sir it's a great pleasure for
me to be with you in this renowned
institution and to have had the
opportunity to listen to extremely
interesting discussions in the two
panels we have this morning I'd like to
congratulate Koenig the mellon
university in the canoe connealy
Endowment for international peace for
putting together this event and the
previous event that was in in Washington
thinks it's quite a challenge and to
bring together issues on the technology
side and the policy side but it really
is quite essential now because they
quite inextricable because a decision on
technology has got policy implications
and a decision on policy will have
technology implications so I really like
to congratulate you for putting together
this this event and also thank you for
the opportunity to talk to you a bit
about itu was mentioned briefly in the
panels and especially the ITU conference
on world the world conference on
international telecommunications that
was mentioned in the lead-up to the
discussions on the internet governance
but despite the fact that I tu is the UN
specialized agency for
telecommunications and information
communication technology ICT s and
everyone today is interested in icts
people throughout the world and
businesses throughout the world more and
more dependent on icts itu is still
fairly unknown organization less known
and most of the UN agencies so it's
always I always take the opportunity to
talk to people a bit about itu and to
explain a bit about it because when it
has been mentioned especially in the in
the lead-up to the the wicked in 2012 i
think there was a lot of
misunderstanding of really what the
organization was was about i think one
of the reasons it's so well so little
known is the fact that it doesn't hit
the headlines very often because where
it's quite effective at doing what it's
supposed to be doing and and if if there
were more problems around like
satellites interfering with each other
or bumping into each other if mobile
phones interfered with televisions and
collect ronix and you weren't able to
use your mobile phone when you move from
one country to another probably itu
would be a bit better known so i'll just
take this opportunity to to run through
the organization briefly and find out a
few fairly unique aspects of ITU first
of all it's a very old organization even
though it's a UN organization it's 80
around 80 years older than the I than
the UN because in fact it's it's the
oldest international organization goes
back to 1865
and the reason that it was created was
because there was a need to sort out the
trans-border interconnection and
interoperability of the telegraph
service in Europe at that time so
European countries got together and
formed this organization it was called
initially the International Telegraph
Union so it was itu right from the
beginning I up till now it's ITU and
really the core function of ITU is still
to ensure international
interconnectivity and interoperability
that's the core function and of course
the the task is much more complicated
today than it was was then and another
unique feature of of ITU is the fact
that it has a very strong private sector
presence quite unusual for the UN
organization to have a large private
sector or membership we have over 700
companies are members of ITU and in fact
much of the work is driven by experts
from from these companies especially on
technical standards work and until
recently of course these companies were
the telecom operators and the telecom
vendors but because I ct's is now
getting into all walks of life and and
many different industry sectors relying
more and more on icts the ITU membership
is becoming much more diverse so now we
have utility companies joining we have
motor manufacturers joining and of
course all the the IT company
and most of the the the Internet
companies joining and we have also by
the way in a number of organizations
that are members of ITU both
international government organizations
with non-governmental organizations as
well and so we have the Internet Society
for example as a member the IETF is a
member and participates in itu and
that's very important for us to have
that close collaboration between the
standards work that we do in itu and the
standards work that the IETF does and in
fact most of the regional internet
registries are also members of ITU and
another feature which i think is quite
unique for for the UN is that we reach
decisions and conclusions almost
invariably through consensus building
very very rare to have a vote in the ITU
and I believe that that culture goes
back you know in history and it's
because there we have to reach agreement
on the use of the radio spectrum and
because radio frequencies don't respect
borders so countries have to get
together and agree on the global use of
frequencies and if they didn't then of
course they'd be interfering with each
other and there would be mutually
degradation of the services that they
offer so this in there in the world
conferences we we hold on this
treaty for on the use of the spectrum
countries have a lot of pressure on them
to to reach a mutually satisfactory
agreement and that is a unique feature I
believe and that's why the work in this
area has been very successful because
countries do make a lot of effort to
compromise on their initial positions
going into a conference so that they can
go away with what everyone can consider
to be mutually satisfactory conclusion
so one of the phrases you often hear at
the end of one of these conferences that
everyone is equally unhappy because they
they all go away not exactly everything
that they wanted but it's good enough
and they can live with it so that's why
we've been very successful for a very
long time in dealing with the issues
especially on radio spectrum but of
course over the hundred and fifty one
years of IT use existence technologies
has changed incredibly across from
telegraph to the telephone from the
radio to television to satellite from
fixed to mobile analog to digital
internet to Internet of Things
artificial intelligence but I tu has
always been striving to bring the
benefits of this technology to all
countries and all the citizens of the
world we have a hundred and ninety-three
governments that are members of ITU
because the majority are developing
countries so it's very important that
we bring the benefits of this technology
to those people with clearly a world
where everyone is connected to the
internet will be a better world be a
better world for being informed for
being educated for receiving health care
and for being productive and really
enjoying a better quality of life so we
need to ensure that all these services
that are now available to people in in
the developed world are also brought to
the people in the developing world and
clearly what's important for them is to
have the full benefit of the internet
and that can only be achieved if they
have access to high-speed broadband
access to the Internet it's only if you
have that high-speed access can you
really benefit from all these innovative
products and services that are available
so this is why I tu always emphasizes
the need for the provision of broadband
and emphasizing the fact that this is
not a luxury anymore but it's an
essential utility that all countries
should have and last year as you know
the the UN adopted the 2030 sustainable
development agenda and with 17
sustainable development goals identified
the very challenging and very ambitious
goals such as ending poverty and hunger
and providing quality education for
and clean water and sanitation ought to
be achieved by 2030 and for each of
these 17 SDGs there are a number of
targets is a total of a hundred and
sixty-nine targets to be achieved and if
you look at these targets it's clear
they can't be achieved without
widespread access to high speed high
speed broadband services and for example
if you look at the target for having the
number of deaths and injuries on roads
clearly that's going to need the use of
icts for smart transport management and
of course it's been well recognized that
ubiquitous cars you know self-driving
cars will greatly reduce accidents so
that's another example of the importance
of icts on just on that target and then
doubling the rate of energy efficiency
clearly that's going to require a lot of
widespread use of smart meters in homes
it's going to need very innovative
energy saving solutions and then another
target is to substantially control the
use of of water to improve the water
efficiency and this again will require
icts especially for managing irrigation
re irrigation is the biggest use of
water and unclearly icts which can be
used to ensure that the
the water is cut off at the right at the
bottom amount of time my amount of time
for irrigation is very important on
reducing water consumption and they can
use the technology also to identify
leaks and to to send people to quickly
stop those leaks so that's another area
and then when we come to looking at
combating climate change again it's
clearly that you can only reduce
greenhouse gas emissions to the extent
that the climate experts say is
necessary through the use of clean
technologies so as I tu is the lead you
an agency for icts clearly have an
important role to play in the achieving
these sustainable development goals and
of course access to the Internet is now
mostly by smart phones smart phones are
now the predominant way that people
throughout the world access the internet
so more and more people requiring faster
connections to download more and more
data puts a lot of pressure on on the
frequency spectrum frequency spectrum
allocated for mobile use and there's
very little spectrum that isn't used you
have to go right up to the 60 70
gigahertz bands where there's less
congestion but other than that all
spectrum is is used so trying to find
allocations for for more mobile spectrum
means taking spectrum away from other
services such as broad broadcasting or
satellites and we have to get
international agreement to that because
if you didn't have globally agreed bands
and you wouldn't be able to use your
phone's moving from one country to
another but also the cost of those
phones would be substantially greater if
you weren't able to benefit from the
economies of scale of a global market so
Darren's to global standards is very
important to reduce costs but also to
ensure interoperability and as I said
the the development of these standards
is something that I tu has been doing
for a very long time especially for the
standards used by networks to carry all
this data and communications almost all
telecom networks rely on itu standards
and with the Internet of Things coming
and billions of devices being connected
and 5g coming along in four or five
years time there's going to be a
tremendous demand on on the network so
this is something that I tu is looking
at currently in developing standards
that will be able to cope with this
demand on the networks as I said
bringing the benefits of this technology
to the developing countries is very much
a goal of the ITU and we develop
guidelines on policies and regulations
that countries could adopt that would
encourage and facilitate the investment
that's necessary to roll out broadband
in in countries and clearly in
developing countries this is quite a
challenge because many of these
countries eighty percent of the
population is living in rural areas so
it's difficult to make a business case
for bringing broadband to some of these
villages
and you've seen that in India in
particular the government is committed
to do this but is having a great
difficulty in finding the right sort of
public-private partnership that would
encourage investment and bring broadband
to these people so clearly these are
challenges that we have to address and
we've seen that there are a lot of
progress is now 2.2 billion smartphones
in use so a lot of progress has been
made but the the bad news is that
according to I to use data gathering
over this year the the divide between
the industrialized countries and the
least developed countries has actually
grown and another gap that's been
identified as the gap between access
from men to the broadband and women is
as around about 200 million less women
accessing the internet than men it's
been estimated so although we have
around about half the world's population
now connected to the Internet still
leaves them like 3.9 billion people
still to be connected and if you look at
the least developing countries it's
quite a sad story in fact it's only one
out of seven people in less developed
countries that have that are connected
so as the industrialized world hurdles
never faster too ubiquitous access and
affordable access to broadband there's a
crucial gap in this when we look at
on a worldwide basis many many people
are losing out on access to education to
health and to finance services that
would greatly benefit their social
economic development the UN produced a
report on progress on SDGs and it will
produce this each July as we go forward
to 2030 but last July's report gave some
startling statistics 60 million children
of primary school age and not attending
school there are 38 million deaths
annually from non communicable diseases
and 6 million children under the age of
5 die every year mostly from easily
preventable causes thirty percent of
urban populations globally are living in
slum like conditions and 950 million
people globally have no means of
sanitation no clean water so these are
huge challenges that we need to do more
to connect the world and to bring the
benefits of broadband to all people
wherever they live and whatever they
means we need to make sure that
hospitals are connected to a ploy
outlying clinics and that the clinics
are connected to two patients we have to
make sure that universities are
connected to schools and schools
connected to all children of all ages
and and also that the government's
themselves are also connected to the
people that they serve the international
community needs to work together to
integrate the UN sustainable development
goals into their into
the country's national development
strategies and it's essential that
governments recognize the power of icts
and broadband to drive progress ICT
skills considered to be lacking in many
countries and this is something that
needs to be addressed because economic
growth depends very much now on on that
there are surprisingly many innovations
occurring in developing countries that
need to be fostered and unsponsored and
and getting this message across the
government's is very important to the
youth the World Bank came out with a
very good statistic that showed that a
ten percent increase in broadband access
in countries can result in up to 1.3
eight percent increase in GDP in the in
the developing world so there was a lot
of statistics and evidence to prove the
benefit of broadband to bring countries
to meet the SDGs and to improve their
social economic development in countries
and we need to work together we have to
work with governments with industry with
civil society non governmental bodies as
well as governmental bodies as has been
said this morning everyone has to work
together we have to cooperate and
coordinate and collaborate if we're
going to achieve these sustainable
development goals and clearly one
essential element will be the trust and
secure and security that people feel
they have when they use this technology
so trust and security is a particularly
important element this is what another
aspect of IT use work is to mr. help
countries
develop their national cybersecurity
strategies to help them with the
computer Incident Response Teams
implementation and to really build
capacity human capacity in these
countries too big take take benefit of
this technology so so since 2011 so it's
quite recent for right to you we have a
new category of membership for academia
you
that
two
over say 90 you
is renowned you pickle side on
so at the very ambitious goals that were
adopted last year the 2030 sustainable
development agenda can can be met so
like to send out that invitation to you
whether you're from this university or
any other university we're very keen to
have you participating in itu i think
i've run out of my time there's a lot
more i could tell you about itu but must
keep to the very strict time that dave
has been keeping to today and thank you
for your attention
we're going to take some questions I
didn't want to make two remarks they
came up during your interior talk the
first is actually Andrew Carnegie when
he came over his first job in Pittsburgh
was working on telegraph systems and so
this is a special interest to us the
second is you talked about i.t use
efforts to help educate and build
instant response teams and of course
Carnegie Mellon's very proud of cert
which was the first interest in response
with that I'd like to open it up for
questions if you have a question please
raise your hand and someone will bring a
mic to you hi mr. secretary do you
anticipate with the recent hacking that
occurred you know allegedly by Russia on
the US election that the UN will have
any role in discipline were in
safeguarding hacking well not on that
specific issue because the UN and I you
will never get into specific issues and
I
Emily you serve ice to you and in fact
mrs.
shin and security in the use of icts so
it's something that we work on but it's
only to bring their benefits of that to
all countries and in all aspects of the
use of ICT so don't look at any specific
national issues thank you um this is tim
over here thank you very much for these
remarks and the 2012 conference in Dubai
has come up a couple of times today
already and I was curious what the ITU
as an organization took away from the
conference based on what we heard
earlier as well yeah thank you very much
for that question now because I feel is
quite a lot of misunderstanding about
that particular conference it clearly
wasn't a success because only half I to
use 193 member states signed up to the
treaty so normally when we have a treat
conference to amend the international
treaty on the use of the radio spectrum
and satellite orbits that's called the
radio regulations and that that treaty
is amended every four years all the
countries present already immediately at
the end of the conference sign up to it
so for us to have a conference where
only half the Member States sign up to
it was was really fun i think you to do
with the lead-up to the conference which
made it on almost impossible to get a
good result because there were a lot of
stories going around but I tu attempting
to take over the internet and the
freedom of the internet was at risk but
other as I was saying in IT we have this
culture of working by consensus so I
don't believe that
it was as dangerous as as was predicted
and but it made countries come to the
conference with very strict red lines
what could be accepted what couldn't be
exempted and and also of course when you
talk about itu sometimes people think of
ITU as as a secretary in Geneva you know
we're we're based in Geneva Secretariat
of around 750 staff but it's a
secretariat it's not an executive itu is
the membership so the membership is 193
governments around 700 private sector
companies 140 academia and a variety of
other organizations that are members so
so it was a lesson I believe for the
membership and then a lot of effort from
the membership to make sure it doesn't
happen again we had a world telecom
policy forum specifically on internet
shortly after that conference it was
very successful we reached a unanimous
agreement on the opinions coming out of
it so I think since then there's been a
lot more effort from member states to to
make sure that you know we can reach
consensus on on these issues and I hope
that when we look at revising this
treaty and a group will start work in
January to look at revising that treaty
I hope very much and this by the way is
is the intention of the chairman of that
group is to look at the elements in the
treaty which is which prevented
countries from signing up to it and if
you look at it is very little in it
that's caused causes a problem and most
of it is not in the treaties in the
preamble or it's in the resolution there
was a resolution on internet which
doesn't say very much but fact it refers
to the internet was a pro
so I would very much hope that you know
we can we can resolve that issue and
have check out these these problem areas
and have a treaty which the full
membership can sign up to
last one last question hi I just wanted
to ask a question a couple weeks ago I
was in Geneva and somebody mentioned to
me that at a recent itu meeting the
subject of this digital object
architecture done' came up and the way
it was presented to me was that it's
potentially an alternative protocol
systems for especially for the internet
of things you know digital identifiers
and security means and it was presented
as though it would be an alternative
model to i can for the Internet of
Things and it might go under the ITU and
I just love to hear your
characterization of that conversation
mm-hmm yes that we had a World
Conference standardization a few weeks
back and so this was an issue that that
was discussing basically the the
technology is incorporated in a sort of
a general standard that was adopted by
the ITU on digital object identifier the
idea of the standard was to ensure
interoperability between different types
of technologies so it wasn't
specifically on that technology but that
technology is being used in the ITU and
is itu offers it to other UN agencies
because it's a unique persistent
and like I'm some
are using it more widely for other
things but it's it's not specifically an
ITU technology and it was promoted let's
say to some extent by some members of
the ITU but it was agreed at the council
this year that it would only be used for
those purposes and IT wouldn't be
promoting it as an alternative to the
DNS but you know as I said we have 193
governments we have 700 private sector
companies etc etc so we have thousands
of experts participating in itu work and
can't be accountable for the views of
all those so you know you shouldn't take
the view is expressed by some certain
individuals in itu meetings as being a
90-year view sometimes happens right I'd
like to thank secretary Johnson once
again
I want to thank everyone here for paying
attention and joining us in this really
important international conversation
that talks about policy and talks about
technology and where they come together
and where some of the sharp edges might
be that we should have a conversation
about going forward I want to thank our
panelists and especially our moderators
who are very busy people as as experts
in the field for taking their time to
come to us in Pittsburgh so let's give
them all one more round of applause I'd
also like to thank once again the deputy
secretary Johnson I'd also like to thank
the carnegie foundation for the generous
gift to make this possible and i'd also
like to thank in particular the staff
who has spent many countless hours
putting together this program and so can
we have the staff that helped put
together this program please stand up
they might actually be outside ready
helping us so thank you Kate Jesse
Meagan Daniel Lauren all roaming around
and so we must recognize their efforts
without this it wouldn't happen i also
want to finally conclude by thanking you
all for coming here and taking time out
of your day we really appreciate it and
we hope that to see you in the future at
future Carnegie Endowment for
international peace and Carnegie Mellon
events thank you very much and have a
great afternoon
[Applause]